hey there Welcome to our guide on
selling digital products online today we
are going to explore the world of
digital goods and why they are such a
GameChanger we will chat about the
difference between physical and digital
products and uncover the reasons why
diving into the digital realm might be
the right move for you curious about the
steps to Kickstart your digital selling
Journey well we've got you covered it's
about Simplicity and success so grab a
seat and let's dive into the exciting
journey of selling digital products
online also if you are interested in
advancing your career consider Perdue
University's post-graduate program in
digital marketing this comprehensive
program offers certification as a
digital marketer through live
Interactive Learning dive deep into the
fundamentals and advanced digital
marketing strategies utilizing Harvard
Business publishing cases student
simulation and Hands-On participation in
20 plus projects access the full
spectrum of digital marketing tools with
chat gbt and AI tools complemented by 35
Plus dedicated resources so what are you
waiting for enroll now now before we
begin make sure to subscribe to our
Channel and press the Bell icon to never
miss an update from Simply learn all
right so in this video we will cover
what are digital products and their
benefits then physical product digital
product why sell a digital product
product selling physical products versus
selling digital products and the steps
to sell digital products online so let's
start with the first topic which is what
are digital products and their benefits
so digital products are intangible items
that can be delivered electronically
like eBooks online courses or software
they don't exist in a physical form so
they can be easily downloaded or
accessed online the great thing about
digital products is that you can sell an
unlimited number of them without wearing
about running out of stoke they also
have a global reach meaning you can sell
to people all over the world without the
need for physical shipping another big
benefit is that they can be cost
effective to produce and distribute as
you don't have to worry about
manufacturing or shipping physical items
plus the delivery process can be
automated making it easier for both you
and your customers for sellers creating
and selling digital products allows them
to Showcase their expertise and
creativity without the limitations of
physical production and distribution all
right now that we have understood about
digital products and its benefits we
need to understand about physical
products and digital products so now
let's understand what are physical
products and digital products So
Physical products are like clothes or
Electronics involve a complex process
from manufacturing to shipping requiring
significant upfront costs digital
products such as ebooks or online
courses are cheaper to create and
distribute allowing creators to focus on
content scale quickly and potentially
earn more in terms of customer
experience buying physical items often
means waiting for delivery and facing
issues like damage or delease on the
flip side digital products offer instant
access upon purchase ensuring a smooth
and convenient experience this
immediately aligns with our fastpaced
lives meeting the demand for quick
satisfaction in the digital Market space
all right so this was about the physical
product and digital products so now
let's let's understand why sell a
digital product so selling a digital
product is a smart choice for many
reasons first they offer a great
scalability meaning you can sell the
same product to many people without
worrying about running out of stock once
you create a digital product you can
easily make copies and deliver them to
customers all over the world without
much effort another big Advantage is
that digital products can be updated and
improved easily this means you can keep
your product fresh and valuable by
making changes whenever you need to
ensure that it stays relevant and useful
to your customers over time so selling
digital products not only allows you to
reach a wide audience effortlessly but
also gives you the flexibility to keep
your product up to R and valuable this
scalability and adaptability make
digital products an attractive option
for sellers looking to maximize their
reach and impact in the Online
Marketplace so now let's understand the
difference between selling physical
products versus selling digital products
so selling physical products involves
managing a complex supply chain
including manufacturing inventory
management and shipping on the other
hand selling digital products eliminates
the complexities associated with
physical inventory and shipping the
Streamline process of delivering digital
products make it easier for businesses
to focus on creating valuable content
and effective marketing strategies the
ease of delivery and accessibility of
digital products not only simplifies
selling process but also opens opens up
opportunities for businesses to reach a
global audience without the logistical
challenges or physical distribution this
shift from physical to digital sales
reflects the evolving landscape of
Commerce where the emphasis is placed on
content creation and customer engagement
rather than the Ines of physical product
management so this was the difference
between selling the physical products
and the digital products now let's have
a look at the interesting part of this
video which is how to actually sell
products online so now first of all
start with the first step which is find
a problem to solve so identifying a
problem is the Cornerstone of crafting a
successful digital product take for an
instance the goal of teaching people to
achieve Fitness at home without
equipment this addresses common
challenges improving Health by providing
a convenient workout solution boosting
confidence through achieving Fitness
schols and saving time and money that
would typically be sent on gym
memberships this approach not only
offers a valuable solution but also
establishes a compelling narrative for
your audience resonating with
individuals seeking practical
resolutions to their challenges your
digital product transcends mere
instructions becoming a transformative
tool for users to overcome obstacles
attain goals and Lead healthier more
confident lives once you're done with
the figuring out the problem you want to
solve then you can proceed to Target
your selling so when it comes to selling
digital marketing products understanding
your target audience is absolutely
essential by identifying and
comprehending the needs and challenges
of your audience you can tailor your
product offerings to directly address
those specific pain points this not only
enhances the relevance of your digital
products but also increases the
likelihood of successful sales to
achieve this it's important to conduct
thorough market research and gather
customer feedback this will provide
valuable insights into the preferences
and behaviors of your Target demographic
allowing you to create digital products
that truly resonates with them by
aligning your offerings with the
specific needs and desires of your
audience you can establish a deeper
connection and build trust ultimately
leading to more successful sales and
long-term customer satisfaction in
essence targeting your selling involves
deep understanding of your audience
enabling you to craft digital products
that genely meet the needs once you have
Target your selling then you can do a
proper research to kick off your V begin
with thorough research utilize Google
keywords planner to Grudge the search
volume for terms link to your concept
this ensures there's an existing
interest in your idea additionally
consult Google Trends to verify a
consistent or growing demand engage with
your potential audience on social media
platforms seek feedback and refine your
idea this proactive approach not only
validates your concept but also
establishes a connection with your
future customers these steps empower for
you with the insights helping you tailor
your product or service to meet genuine
Market needs so once you know the
marketing needs then you can proceed
with creating a marketing plan so
crafting a marketing plan is pivotal for
successful online product sales
establish a unique selling proposition
that differentiates your product utilize
social media platforms strategically to
build brand awareness and engage with
your audience Implement email marketing
campaigns to Neal leads and drive
conversions incorporate paid advertising
judicial
focusing on platforms aligning with your
audience regularly analyze metrics and
customer feedback to refine your
strategies a well-rounded marketing plan
and shows a comprehensive and effective
approach to selling products online so
after creating a marketing plan you can
finally launch an online store all right
so starting your online store is a
breeze with platforms like Shopify or
Etsy they are userfriendly and perfect
for beginners Shopify lets you easily
customize your store manage payment
securely and use helpful apps on the
other hand Etsy is great for Creative
Fox selling handmade or vintage items
these platforms make it simple to set up
your shop without the hustle of building
a website with easy designs and lot of
support they are go to choice for a
straightforward way to dive into online
selling all right so this is how you can
launch an online store now we will talk
about the best platforms to sell so
selecting the best platform is crucial
for effectively selling digital
marketing products when deciding on a
platform it's important to access each
one based on factors such as the type of
product you're offering your target
audience and your business objectives
there are several popular platforms that
cater to different needs and preferences
so we'll start with the first one which
is selfie selfie this platform offers
simple and userfriendly interface for
creating your own storefront or
embedding products on your website it
also provide tools for boosting sales
and promoting products through social
media next one is podia podia allows you
to sell digital products subscriptions
and online courses it also supports
features such as hosting webinars
creating lending pages and building a
community around your content all right
now at number three we have Shopify so
Shopify known for its flexibility and
advanced features Shopify enables the
sale of both physical and digital
products it it offers extensive
customizability along with tool for
inventory management analytics and
marketing then there is gumroad gumroad
is designed to help you sell digital
products directly to your audience it
boosts a simple and intuitive interface
as well as features like email marketing
analytics and payment processing all
right then there is ety while ety is
known for its catering to creative and
design Focus sellers it also allows the
sale of digital products such as art
crafts patn and printables in addition
to physical Goods after that we have
teachable so teachable platform is an
online tool that allows individuals to
create and sell their own courses it
provides a userfriendly interface for
course creators to organize content
offer multimedia lessons and engage with
students student can access courses
learn at their own pace and often
receive support through discussion
forums or direct communication with the
instructor it's a way for people to
share their expertise and for Learners
to access a variety of educational
resources conveniently from anywhere
within an internet connection so
selecting the best platform depends on
factors such as the type of product
you're offering for instance if you're
selling a digital artwork a platform
like Etc known for its focus on handmade
and unique items might be good fit on
the other hand if you're offering online
courses a platform like teachable
designed specifically for course
creators could be more suitable by
carefully evaluating these platforms you
can make an informed decisions that
aligns with your specific needs and
maximizes the potential for success in
your digital product Venture and there
you have it Fox we have reached the end
of our guide on selling digital products
online we hope you have gained valuable
insights into the benefits of digital
Goods the difference between physical
and digital sales and the steps to
thrive in the digital Marketplace
remember Simplicity is the key and
success is just around the corner all
right guys with that we have come to the
end of this video If you like this video
please give it a thumbs up I hope it
really helped you all thanks for
watching stay safe and keep learning
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in cuttingedge domains
including d data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here